et got an exclusive invite behind the
scenes of dirty 30 I love love love a
party movie like one of my favorite
movies of all time is can't hardly wait
can't feel my legs what you got the
intimacy of a house party you know like
harsh Mars like I want to rifle through
people's belongings you know it's just
an endearing kind of relationship
dynamic movie all wrapped in a robbing
house party really it kind of
encompasses it yeah have a bet to see if
you get robbed a guitar you are there
gonna be any nods to camp Takota in this
movie any wink wink intense I hate it
when the someone answ got say goodbye to
my best friend can't code I love you so
and
öktem no compress cops no there's not
really any easter eggs well I guess kind
of an unintentional nod is that I got to
bring in a lot of our really talented
friends to be in this and play really
ridiculous characters that's me hey
rhett and Link yeah they were so good it
was originally a character was one
person and when we found out that they
both wanted to do it it was made me
wrote it in to two people dude became
dude number one and dude number two is
pretty much their friendship
thank God cuz we think he sucks what's
your best tease for the movie it's going
to be super duper fun it'll be a
nostalgic it'll be the house party you
wish you'd gone to in high school but
this one is occupied by a bunch of idiot
adults yeah a symphony of dude yeah I
think that encompasses it